a warning that this exclusive report
from our home editor jason farrell
contains details that some viewers may
find distressing
here in hull a police investigation into
a gang of alleged child abusers has
stalled he'd like pick me up from school
in like the middle of the day then give
me alcohol and just rape me in this
house
but we're gathering evidence from young
women who say they were being groomed
and raped by connected men in a story
that perhaps explains why the vast
majority of the uk's sexual assault
investigations never reach court
one of the alleged victims we're calling
anna kept a diary
[Music]
first of november 2018
physical abuse
bitten
hit slapped dragged by legs
anna's account of abuse starts with an
older boy who she trusted until he
turned violent
rip
i can't write anymore yet
too fresh
after this she seems to get entangled in
violent sexual relationships with a
number of men she says she feels
threatened by them and that one made
that clear to anna when taking her to
this forest
he was saying how he could kill me here
and bury me and no one would realize
and then he like strangled me and
everything like just went black and i
remember i could see like the trees and
they just all went black
alongside the threats there's also a
kind of brainwashing sometimes anna
thinks the men love her she seems wired
to their control
in her diary she says she feels like
she's living a double life and is
controlled like a puppet
you know a lot of people sort of go why
do
girls go back to these guys why do they
keep going back
was it purely fear
so like the main thing that was in my
head was if i don't do this something
worse is going to happen
and it's just the whole cycle you're in
you just
it's hard to get out of
you just normalize to it
and no one was offering us help to get
us out of it so you kind of think well
it can't be that bad if no one's
bothered
joe wagstaff is a psychotherapist who's
worked with victims of these gangs
including anna in the beginning i think
there is an element that it feels like
they're in a friendship or a
relationship and that's i think that's
where that brainwashing comes in as well
in that actually i've done this for you
and i've given you everything
and that would be true they have done
that so now you need to pay me back
anna was over 16 when the abuse started
so during the police investigation there
was a greater need to prove she was
coerced however that evidence does seem
to exist firstly she took photos of the
bruising on her neck and arms which
match injuries she mentions in her diary
what's more she regularly updated her
school's welfare officer who made her
own log on what was happening
22nd january 2019
anna had a small red mark on her left
cheek i could see bloodstains on her
left knee
she says she knows what they do is harm
but she normalizes it but if she ignores
their calls messages then there is more
harm
over the course of 18 months there are
290 logs mostly referring to concerns
about child exploitation and as teacher
sees messages saying i'll actually kill
you don't ignore me from a man who's
been outside school
that's what the predator will do
watching
you know where they are what they're
doing
anna provided over a thousand pages of
evidence which we've shared with former
police chief and one of the uk's leading
investigators into child exploitation
jim gamble you know i i think having
looked at the information that is there
there is no true consent and that i can
see and anyone
anyone who just looks at a few of these
papers will see that so consent needs to
be freely given it needs to be a true
consent it doesn't come with
strangulation marks does it well no it
doesn't it doesn't come with threats to
to kill your parents it doesn't come you
know with threats to be waiting for you
outside school
it's clear anna's school and police had
real-time knowledge that she was
repeatedly going missing and there were
multiple concerns she was being
intimidated and abused yet they seem
unable to stop it
in anna's diary her frustration comes
off the page in emotions in lists of
days when she's abused and days when
she's reported missing in graphic
accounts of the assaults and amid notes
about school homework there are thoughts
like this today in science class i learn
every cell in our body is replaced every
seven years
how lovely is it
one day i will have a body you never
touched
and i tell you
you know that's something that i will
remember
forevermore it's so powerful we're
almost at the point where we need to
declare war on this type of behavior we
need to say it is a priority it's not
just about exploitation it is about rape
by appointment it is about brutal
individuals who are hurting our children
in our next report we speak to
humberside police they've told us
following arrests and thousands of lines
of inquiry they haven't reached the
evidence threshold to take this to court
so far we've told you about two alleged
victims but three others have given sky
news supporting testimony and the
alleged victim we speak to next hasn't
been interviewed by the police
jason farrell sky news
[Music]